ونحيكم متابعينا الى مناقشات ملفنا
الثانيين منذ العاشر من مارس واضطرابات
القطاع المصرفي العالمي متواصله البدايه
كانت من الولايات المتحده مع انهيار بنك
سيليكون
فاليتش ما يعتبر اكبر افلاس بنكي يحدث منذ
عام 2008 الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تعهد
بفعل كل ما يتطلبه الامر لضمان سلامه
النظام المصرفي ولطمانه الناس ان اموالهم
امنه في حين يسعل المسؤولون في اوروبا
واليابان واستراليا واماكن اخرى الى تخفيف
القلق المفاجاه الثانيه كانت مع الاعلان
عن صفقه تاريخيه قيمتها 3.25 مليار دولار
باستحواذ بنك يو بي اس الاكبر في سويسرا
على ثاني اكبر مصرف في البلاد لانهاء ازمه
الاخير وحمايه النظام العالمي من موجات مد
مماثله تهدد النظام المصرفي العالمي وبعد
الاعلان عن الصفقه تعهد المجلس الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي البنك المركز الامريكي والبنك
المركزي الاوروبي وبنوك مركزيه كبرى اخرى
بتعزيز السيوله في السوق وبدعم المصارف
ويرى محللون ان كل ما يحدث من انهيار في
البنوك هو على خلفيه تغير عالمي اكبر
بكثير وهو الارتفاع الحاد في الفائده
الامريكيه على الدولار خلال شهور الماضيه
حيث كانت البنوك المركزيه في جميع انحاء
العالم بما في ذلك الاحتياطي والفدراليو
الامريكي
ترفع اسعار الفائده في محاوله لابطاء
الاقتصاد تخفيف الضغط الذي يؤدي الى
ارتفاع الاسعار لكن هذه الاجواء اعادت الى
الواجهه المخاوف المرتبطه بالازمه الماليه
العالميه لعام 2008 وسط تساؤلات عن مدات
تاثير ازمه البنوك العالميه الراهنه على
منطقه الشرق الاوسط
مصرف كريدي سويس
يصنف البنك من بين اكبر مدير الثروات في
العالم هو واحد من ثلاثين بنكا عالميا
مهما على مستوى النظام يمتلك كريدي سويس
بنك سويسريا محليا وشركه اداره ثروات
وخدمات مصرفيه استثماريه
يعد كريدي سويس البنك الخاصه لعدد كبير من
رواد الاعمال والاثرياء والشركات
في اول تعاملاته بعد صفقه الاستحواذ اسهم
كريدي سويس تراجعت 60% كما تراجعت اسهم يو
بي اس بثمانيه.
نناقشه هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بيروت
الدكتور جهاد الحكيم استاذ التمويل
الدوليه بالجامعات الامريكيه اهلا بيكوا
من بيروت من او من ميزورين نور الدين
الحموري يا كبير استراتيجي الاسواق في
سكواد اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان
ابدا مع الاستاذ نور الدين استاذ نور
الدين خليني ابدا معك باخر المخاوف
واكبرها ربما البعض يخاف من اعاده سماريو
2008 هل هذا وارد
الوضع مختلف كليا عن ما حصل خلال عام 2008
سواء كان من القوانين وايضا من ناحيه حتى
رؤوس اموال البنوك الشيء الجيد الذي
شهدناه والذي لبسناه خلال الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه بانه البنوك المركزيه
وايضا الهيئات التنظيميه تحركت بشكل سريع
جدا بمعنى ما شاهدنا في موضوع سيليكون
فالي بنك اتخذنا الوقت حوالي تقريبا 48
ساعه فقط لكي ينتهي الامر او على الاقل
ايقاف البنك عن العمل ونحن نتحدث عن بنك
او تم اغلاق البنك وهو لازالت اصوله
بال200 مليار دولار تقريبا بينما الخساره
التي يتحدث عنها البن كانت لا تتخطى
مليارين وربع المليار دولار فقط اما
بالنسبه وايضا حتى كرين سويس كذلك الامر
لم يتحمل الموضوع اكثر من حوالي تقريبا
ايام فقط بينما خلال فتره الازمه الماليه
العالميه كانت البنوك المركزيه في حاله من
ليس الحديث عن عدم الاكتراث بينما اخذ
بشكل كبير جدا حتى شهدت انخفاض في الاصول
ومن ثم تدخلت كانت هذه الاصول او اسعار
هذه الاصول لا شيء بالمقابل او المقارنه
ما كانت عليه قبل قبل ذلك لذلك لا اعتقد
انه مشابه جدا لما حصل في عام مختلف كليا
ولا ننسى انه ايضا بدا هذا الموضوع بموضوع
الاشاعه
بانه بنك اس بي بي على شفى الانهيار وحصل
ما حصل وما يعرف بالبنكرا او بمعنى انه
الجميع ذهب لسحب الاموال وقد يحدث ذلك لاي
بنك فيما لو شاهدنا نفس الموضوع انه هناك
اشاعات بانه هذا البنك من كشف او لا
يستطيع ان يتحمل سحب الاموال دكتور جهاد
هل تتفق مع ضيفي او هل انت متفائل نسبيا
مثله بان هناك عوامل مختلفه فالنتيجه
ستكون مختلفه ربما لن نكون في اطار ما
شاهدناه في 2008 ام لا حتى وان كانت
العوامل مختلفه قد تكون النتيجه نفسها في
هذا في هذا في هذه الحاله ومع هذه
المتغيرات
شكرا للاستضافه لا اريد ان اقارن بين ازمه
2008 وما يحدث اليوم لكن ما يحدث اليوم
خطير جدا ولا ينبئ في شيء جيد ما رايناه
من زواج قصري بين يو بي اس وكريدي سويس
وتغيير القوانين وعدم الرجوع الى
المساهمين وعدم الاخذ برايهم
وتحميل حمله الكوكو بونز او ما يعرف
بالسندات القابله للتحويل وتحميلهم
الخساره
هذه هذا امر
جديد جدا بالنسبه لنا وهذا سيؤثر على حركه
رؤوس الاموال فلا اعتقد ان من لديه الكثير
من الاموال في الاسواق الناشئه
والاقتصاديات الناشئه سيتشجع بعد اليوم
بان يرسل هذه الاموال الى
المصارف في الغرب في كالمصارف في سويسرا
لانه
الغرب
العالم الدكتور جهاد فقط نتخوف من اجل
العام هنالك بشكل عام
هنالك بشكل عام هنالك بيئه غير مطمئنه ولا
تشجع على ان على تحويل الاموال الى
المصارف في الخارج
وهنالك مخاوف عديده
وهذا يجب ان يخفى علينا ان البنك مثل
كريدي سويس كان كانت قيمته حوالي 100
مليار في سنه 2007 قد انخفضت قيمته الى
سبعه مليار يوم الجمعه الفائت من يقول انه
ليس هنالك مشكله في القطاع المصرفي
العالمي هو
يختبئ وراء اصبعه هنالك مشكله كبيره جدا
ورفع الفوائد
بشكل كبير وبهذه السرعه قد ك خسائر كبيره
لحمله السندات ومن قال ومن كان يروج ان من
يقوم بحمل في محفظته الماليه السندات فهو
لا يريد المخاطر فهذا يرجع الى كل محفظه
يمكن انك ستضطرين الى بيع هذه السندات
اليوم لانك هي بحاجه الى سيوله معينه
فعندها ستتكبدين خسائر جامحه وكبيره جدا
وبالتالي الازمه الموجوده في القطاع
المصري في العالمي هي جديه وكبيره جدا
وعدم
دكتور جهاد حضرتك تتحدث عن مخاوف مخاوف
بالغه الاهميه وقد تطال الكل من له سندات
من ليست له سندات من يضع امواله في
المصارف استاذ نور الدين هذه المخاوف هل
يمكن ان تؤشر الى
امكانيه انهيار النظام المصرفي العالمي هل
هذا وارد او مستبعد
لا يمكن استبعاد شيء بالتحديد اتفق مع
الدكتور تتحدث ايضا بان موضوع الرفع اسعار
الفوائد بالتاكيد هناك بكل من سالتيه في
الاسواق على الاقل خلال فتره الثلاثه اشهر
الماضيه انه الفترات الامريكي لن يقوم
بالتوقف عن رفع اسعار الفوائد الا حتى ان
يقوم
بكسر شيء معين او يعني كمقوله بانه لن
يتوقف حتى
يعني يضرب شيء في الاسواق او ان يكون
لدينا نوع من الحدث وهذا الشيء الذي حصل
حتى وان كانت النتيجه انهيار النظام
البنكي او المصرفي
اعتقد انه لن تصل لن لن تصل المرحله الى
انهيار النظام البنكي لا اعتقد انه
الفيدرالي او حتى البنوك المركزيه
العالميه ستخطئ نفس الخطا الذي اخطاته في
عام 2008 عندما تركت الامور تذهب الى نقطه
لا عوده وحتى ايضا بعد الانهيار اعترفت
هذه البنوك بانه كان من الافضل لنا ان
ننقذ بنك لمن براذر على الاقل بينما انقذت
الشركات بعدها بايام كشركه يعني يحتاج الى
10 مليار بينما احتاج 800 مليار وتم
اعطائها المبلغ من قبل كونغرس الامريكي
لكن الموضوع يصل الى مرحله انه هل لدينا
بالفعل القدره على الاستمرار برفع اسعار
الفوائد بالتاكيد لا هل سيقوم الفيدرالي
هذا الاسبوع برفع اسعار الفوائد هذا ما
تنتظر الاسواق اعتقد انه من الممكن
الفيدرالي ان يفاجئ الاسواق من جديد برفع
ربع النقطه لكن سيتحدث بوضع متوازن بانه
علينا ان ناخذ بعض الاحتياطات او نعود
لخطوه الى
لننتظر المزيد من ننتظر من المزيد من
الارقام هل نحن على اعتاب ركود الركود
اصبح في الوقت الحالي مطلوب اكثر من اي
وقت اخر لسبب مهم جدا اذا كانت معدلات
الفوائد التي تم رفعها على مدار العام
الماضي بما فيها ثلاثه رفعات بخمسه وسبعين
نقطه اساس لم تكبح شماح التضخم بالقدر
الذي هو مطلوب فقد يكون من الافضل ان ندفع
الاقتصاد العالمي الى مرحله الركود ليعود
التضخم الى التراجع بفتره اسرع مما
يتطلبها تطلبها داخل
تطرحها يعني الركود الذي كان البعض يتخوف
منه او يستبعده حضرتك تضعه كحل من الحلول
ما رايك دكتور جهاد
برايي ان هنالك مشكله كبيره نواجهها في
سنه 2023
وصعود اونصه الذهب الى فوق الالفين دولار
اليوم هذا يدل اننا نحن في مشكله كبيره
وعلى الرغم من انخفاض برميل النفط الى 70
دولار ما زلنا في مشكله كبيره جدا ويجب
على المصارف المركزيه توخي الحذر لانه ان
لم يتعظوا وسيكملون مسيره رفع الفوائد
ستكون العواقب كبيره جدا ليس فقط على
البلدان الناميه التي راينا ان نتدهورت
عملاتها نتيجه رفع الفوائد في فتره في
فتره سابقه انما ايضا على الاقتصاديات
الكبيره كالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي والمصارف الكبرى حيث هم
عاده اقطاب ولديهم اكبر البورصات في
العالم ولديهم تدفقات ماليه كبيره
لقد لم ينفك الامريكي الفائده من جديد مره
اخرى قد يرفعه مره اخرى او تعتقد بان هناك
مفاجاه قد يعلن عنها
يتوقع او تتوقع الاسواق ان يقوم برفع
الفائده بربع بالمئه ولقد راينا ان الاي
سي بي او البنك المركزي الاوروبي قد رفع
الاسبوع الفائت الفائده بنصف بالمئه ولم
ياخذ بعين الاعتبار ان هنالك مشكله كبيره
تواجه القطاع المصرفي برمته فبرايه يجب
توخي الحذر لان هذا ما يحدث في سنه 2023
هو جدي جدا
وراينا ان البنك الدولي وصندوق النقد
الدولي لم ينفكوا عن تخفيض توقعاتهم
بالنسبه للنمو لسنه 2023 اكثر من مره وهذا
يدل اننا نحن في على الرغم من انخفاض
اسعار المواد الاوليه بشكل كبير
وراينا ان التضخم الاساسي رب
ليس هو
مرتفعا جدا لكن لم يتم السيطره عليه لكن
برايي انه ليس هنالك من مبرر بالمضي قدما
بهذه برفع الفوائد ونحن امام هذه المخاطر
فلنعطي بعض الوقت للاسواق لان ما يعرف
بالهارتيز اي المواد الاوليه قد انخفضت
اسعارها ولا ولا يجب فقط التركيز على
التضخم الاساسي او الجوهري فلنعطيه بعض
الوقت لان ارتفاع الفوائد هي مرتفعه عند
مستويات تاريخيه بالنسبه لاخر عقد من
الزمن فلنعطي بعض الوقت في الاصوات
لتستوعب هذه الفوائد المرتفعه نعم وقت مهم
جدا ولكن في مقابله هناك الخوف الخوف قد
يدفع اصحاب الاموال او
من لهم سيوله في البنو ك ان يسحبها وهذا
ما قد يعمق كذلك المشكله وهنا السؤال
استاذ نور الدين هل القطاع البنكي امن
بالدرجه التي يجب الاحتفاظ بالسهوله داخل
البنوك ام ان هناك هواجس هناك حظر ويجب
سحب هذه الاموال
واستثمارها في اشياء اخرى خوفا من افلاس
عام
بعتقد انها امنه لسبب مهم جدا كذلك الامر
بعد موضوع
تحديدا ان نظرتي حاده الى شيء مهم جدا
البنك لم يخفي شيء البنك هو الذي اعلن عن
خسارته البنك هو الذي قام به وذكر باعلان
واضح وصريح اننا خسائر بالسندات بواقع حول
المليارين كذلك الامر هو لم يشتري
اصول سيئه او لم يقامر هو بالنهايه اشترى
سندات حكوميه امريكيه مدعومه بغطاء حكومي
هذه من جهه الجهه الاخرى موضوع ايضا انه
القطاع المصرفي امن ام لا بعد هذه المشكله
التي حصلت في بنك اعلنت ايضا مؤسسه
التامين على الودائع الفيدراليه الامريكيه
بانه كل الودائع مضمونه ليس فقط ودائع ال
250 الف دولار لانه ايضا معظم الشعب
الامريكي لا يملك 250 الف دولار في في
البنك لذلك
موجوده ولكن غدا ستكون موجوده
وحافظت عن ان البنك
لم يهم وان كان قام البنك ام لا ان كان
اخطا ام لا ما يهمه هو ودائعه موجوده
لهذا السبب تم انقاذ البنك بهذه الفتره
السريعه لانه هناك وجود اصول تكفي بشكل
كامل لتغطيه هذه الاموال وانه البنك لم
يكن هو بالفعل في وضع او بوضع بوضع افلاس
سوى انه كان لدينا ما يعرف بالكلاسيك او
بمعنى الجميع في وقت واحد طلب سحب الاموال
وهذا شيء ايضا خطير جدا حتى خلال الوضع
الحالي ان لديك مؤثر من المؤثرين على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لديه لنفرض جدلا
لديه مليون متابع ذكر بانه ذهب الى البنك
اليوم ولم يستطع سحب مبلغ 10,000 من
الممكن ان يؤدي هذه التغريده او هذا
الحديث على ان يكون لدينا بنكرا على احد
البنوك وان يتم نفس الموضوع كما شاهد مع
او غيره من البنوك
القوانين مختلفه موضوع 2008 وموضوع ايضا
المخاطر من معادلات التضخم نعم هناك مخاطر
بالتاكيد لكنها لم تصل بعد الى موضوع ان
يكون لدينا افلاس او ان يكون لدينا انهيار
كامل بدليل الاسواق لا زالت في وضع جيد
حتى بعد
اسمح لي على المقاطعه لاختم باختصار شديد
شديد دكتور جهاد حول هذه النقطه انكل لك
تعليق
بالنسبه الي القول ان ليس هنالك من
مسؤوليه يتحملها المصارف المركزيه
والحكومات هذا غير صحيح لان السياسات
الانفلاجيه في فتره جائحه كورونا
وسياسه الفوائد المنخفضه جدا هي مندفعت
الكثير من المصارف بان لا تاخذ المخاطر
المدروسه المطلوبه وهذه السياسه
الانفلاجيه هي من سببت بالتضخم وهي من
دفعت بعض المصارف بان لا تنوع مثلا
محفظاتها الماليه كما يجب اخذت مخاطر اكثر
من اللازم وبالتالي المصارف اليوم هي في
في
وقت او في ظرف حرج جدا ويجب توخي الحذر في
سنه 2023 كي لا ناخذ الاقتصاد العالمي
والقطاع المصرفي لمكان لا يحمد عقبه
هذه التطورات وموقف الفيدرالي الامريكي
كذلك من كل هذا شكرا جزيلا لكما دكتور
جهاد الحكايه استاذ التمويل الدولي
بالجامعه الامريكيه في بيروت والاستاذه
نور الدين الحموري كبير استراتيجيه
الاسواق في سكورت شكرا لكمما